"IT WAS
THE BEST OF TIMES, IT WAS THE
DURST OF TIMES."
IF YOU'RE NOT AWARE OF LIMP
BIZKIT, CONGRATULATIONS!
YOU'RE LUCKY!
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
THESE GOONS TOOK THE WORST PARTS
OF HEAVY METAL AND HIP-HOP AND
BLENDED THEM TOGETHER IN A
MUSICAL DIARRHEA THAT DUDES WITH
NECK TATTOOS LISTEN TO AS THEY
SKATEBOARD TO WORK EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE IN THEIR MID-40S.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
IT'S LIMP BIZKIT LEAD SINGER
FRED DURST'S BIRTHDAY!
MEANING HE IS ONE STEP CLOSER TO
THAT BIZKIT BEING LIMP.
COMEDIANS, YOUR CHALLENGE IS TO
TELL ME WHAT THIS LIVING GOATEE
HAS ON HIS AMAZON WISHLIST.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
WIL.
>> DIGNITY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
FELICIA.
>> VITAMIN WATER, HOT DOG
FLAVORED.
>> CHRIS: ( BLEEP ).
POINTS.
APRIL.
>> A CUSTOM T-SHIRT THAT SAYS,
"AT LEAST I'M NOT ROBERT DURST."
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
FELICIA.
>> A BIG-MOUTHED BILLY BASS.
( LAUGHTER )
REMEMBER THAT?
>> CHRIS, OF COURSE, I REMEMBER
IT! IT PROBABLY PLAYS HIS SONGS.
IT OCCURS TO ME THAT EVERY ONE
OF THESE THINGS COULD ALSO WORK
ON ROBERT DURST.
>> CHRIS: "WHAT DID YOU DO TO
MUSIC?"
"I KILLED IT ALL, I GUESS."
WIL.
>> A DAD WHO LISTENED.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS, YEAH.
FELICIA.
>> CAPTAIN TOAD TREASURE TRACKER
FOR THE WII U.
>> CHRIS: APRIL.
>> A TANDEM BIKE SO HE CAN RIDE
WITH KID ROCK.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.